first of all you know is a very
important country in the world
everybody's look up to the United States
for the leadership because
technologically economically politically
such a important country in the whole
world is the number one country that way
when the your presidential primaries go
on the whole world watches it and
discusses about it in every single cafe
the symbol single place people meet they
are talking about the election in the
United States so that's the importance
because your election is not simply
election in a particular country it has
an impact for the whole block so that's
a role that you have have already in
your very existence of it what do we
would expect that the United States lead
the world in a piece situation doesn't
go into Wars because if identities get
into war the whole war world gets into
trouble so we wouldn't like that to
happen the United States is not a war
maker it's a peacemaker because the
United States is one country which can
really bring peace wherever the trouble
spot is their influence can bring peace
and that would be most helpful in
improving the quality of life of the
poor people because war takes away all
the attention all the action needed to
be done for poor people are derailed
completely Iraq war itself has derailed
world so much that we will take years to
get back to our position where we wanted
to make a beautiful world for ourselves
in this new millennium that we just
started recently so this is very
important that that thing happens and
then pay attention to the innovative
activities which can be used for helping
poor people get our poverty ideas like
social businesses ideas like microcredit
ideas like
technology information technology
particularly bringing to the poorest
people this is the country which is at
the top of the technology world so if
the attention is paid if a nation can
keep on designing one after another
enjoyment gadgets iPods and iPhones and
so if this same attention is given to
their poor people the tremendous kind of
gadgets can be created with information
technology will make life of the poor
people absolutely easy and absolutely
easy to get out of poverty it's a
question of where we direct your mind
the moment you direct your mind to this
poverty show the whole world will
benefit from that poorer the number of
poor will decline very sharply into it
and if young people in this country can
be encouraged that this is an issue that
is a say we can play a very important
role and these are the areas that we can
play important role in designing right
kind of social businesses wherever we
see a problem what kind of social
business can be designed there what kind
of technology we can bring to the
poorest person so that he and she's
empowered to use her talent her
creativity to take to change her life
what kind of resources can flow if
United States wants to put money
individual and not government money
government foreign aid is important but
that's a different kind of thing but if
important private money individuals
money can come it's a huge money it can
change the poverty situation completely
if that money is used properly in terms
of microcredit in terms of social
businesses that will be a tremendous
help in terms of technology design in
terms of holding competitions to bring
newer and newer designs involving the
whole world to participate in to it
United States can play a tremendous
amount of leadership role particularly
young people in in this country can play
very vital role in providing the
position